bonsoir soyez les bienvenus en basse
normandie nous sommes toujours en direct
du village des jeux équestres mondiaux
parc des expositions de caen troisième
jour de compétition est de plus en plus
de spectateurs notamment aux alentours
du stade d'ornano qui accueille les
épreuves de dressage reportage de
thierry cléon et de l'oit blache
d'ornano à l'heure de pointe djo m
ce qui frappe ici c'est qu'il y à là que
partout pour entrer dans le stade ou
tout simplement pour manger fournil de
beaulieu température ambiante 30 35
degrés climat international
autant dire que derrière les fourneaux
ont frôlé la surchauffe
je suis là
que tout jeu équestre
habituellement ici quatre personnes
travaillent derrière la caisse à
l'occasion des jeux
la famille est venu donner un coup de
pouce cinq paires de mains au plus tôt
le matin en fait avant les épreuves on a
du monde dès 6h30 pour le petit déjeuner
quand les épreuves commencent vers 8h30
9h puis tranquille on refait une mise en
place ont rempli le magasin et sarre
attaques vers midi après midi jusqu'à 14
heures les gens rentraient la sortie
c'est que du pain est question peint ici
on s'y connaît la fameuse baguette choix
1,16 fait l'unanimité surtout en
sandwich les ventes sont tout simplement
multipliée par quatre là on en fait un
peu près 600 600 650 128 par le jour
et cela sans compter les quiches burger
viennoiseries et les pâtisseries
bref à beaulieu sans attendre la fin des
gipn on peut dire que les jeux semblent
déjà faits allez faisons le bilan
sportif de cette journée bonsoir anthony
masto on commence par le dressage et le
nouveau sacre de charlotte dujardin qui
comme son nom ne l'indiqué pas est
britannique charlotte du jardin sur son
très beau vallée gros un cheval aux
landais de 12 ans avec qui elle a
déroulé une reprise quasiment parfaite
avec cette médaille d'or charlotte
dujardin confirme sa place de meilleure
cavalière de dressage au monde
les médailles d'argent et de bronze
reviennent tel à l'allemagne pour les
cavaliers français
en revanche l'aventuré s'arrête là marc
boblet et nobel dream qui avait été
rattrapé de justesse 1 pour participer à
ce grand prix spécial termine à la 24e
place
arnaud serre et robinson de la faune de
massa font te une honorable 27e place
on attend maintenant avec impatience les
reprise libre en musique pour les 15
meilleurs cavaliers arrivés en tête
aujourd'hui ce sera vendredi et ce sera
du grand spectacle emilie andré jacques
goupil bonsoir vous êtes notre
consultant les performances des français
ne sont pas si mal faut pas oublier
qu'il ya quatre ans à lexington il n'y
avait pas de tricolores en dressage
exactement et puis on rêver d'un podium
faut remonter à marguerittes autocrates
en écornant disons qu'on était dans les
années 90 non non on sait maintenant
qu'on a notamment avec les deux chevaux
de tarnos et de marque des chevaux qui
ont le potentiel pour les jeux
olympiques
ça c'est la bonne nouvelle c'est ce
qu'on voulait était dans le grand prix
c'était pour rivaliser avec les gros et
charlotte dujardin fo fo voit la fois un
extraterrestre et dimanche vendredi pour
les reprises libre en musique vous a
même ceux qui ne connaissent pas vous
allez voir le cheval danse et vous
assure ça vous apporte énormément
d'émotion nancy aura ça le bilan
maintenant anthony empara dressage où un
millier ont paré dressage aussi la
grande bretagne fait de très bons
résultat avec notamment cette médaille
d'or tout à l'heure pour le britannique
lee personnes dans le grade 1
pour ce qui est des cavaliers français
et bien vous allez le voir le normand
samuel katell sur son cheval le mogador
de volanges a terminé 15e de son groupe
ce matin et cet après midi anne
frédérique royan et valérie salesses
termine respectivement 12e et 15e de
leur groupe
ml on est content pour valérie seles qui
était hier soir sur notre plateau c'est
pas si mal même chose que pour les cas
les dresseurs objectif les jeux
olympiques
ils ont travaillé ils ont pris des
risques petite déception pour sam qui
lui descend un petit peu il fait
quelques fautes mais d autres non on est
dans les scores on est dans la
progression donc je pense qu'ils vont
être content ce soir et sony vous traite
d'extraterrestres merci see alors il sur
notre site internet focus sur les
supporters des bleus aux épreuves de
dressage notre adresse bastière et
normandie point france 3 point fr vous
retrouverez également tout ce que vous
voulez savoir sur ces jeux équestres
mondiaux et notamment des articles sur
les cavaliers de parra dressage qui
concourent sur l'hippodrome de la
prairie devant des rangs il faut le dire
très clairsemé c'est vrai que ce n'est
que la deuxième fois que le que cette
discipline est présente aux jeux
équestres une discipline qui peine à
trouver son public et c'est bien dommage
pauline la truite et stéphanie lemaire
s'est le plus jeunes spectateurs de la
tribune
nolan à six semaines il est venu voir le
normand sam alcatel son papa qu'il
soutient déjà à sa manière il allait se
remettront pas passé comme ça mais
qu'at-elle participe à ses premiers jeux
pour lui c'est l'occasion de faire
découvrir sa passion même si le public
se fait un peu désirer
on regrette un peu parc à l'hippodrome
alors que les dresseurs ils sont
adorables
après bon c'est un peu le bazar dans la
billetterie et où je pense qu'il ya eu
quelques problèmes de gestion par
rapport à ça on est très bien ne sont
pas trop pas comblé après on est super
content d'être ici et de et de faire
parce qu'on sait faire puisque les gens
connaissent pas trop pas trop ce que
c'est
c'est vrai je les tribunes se
remplissent doucement en fonction du
temps et entre deux rayons de soleil on
découvre un public éclectique composé de
passionnés venus de loin mais aussi des
voisins curieux qui expérimentent les
jours c'est très intéressant se
connaissaient pas du tout et on
découvrait est vraiment un grand plaisir
ils sont un très haut niveau déjà avec
un handicap surmonter leur handicap
c'est pour moi c'est formidable je suis
très admirative moi aussi je suis un
câblier des parades à fait sage et nous
voulons voir les niveaux et câblés
internationaux et nous avons vieux quai
ligny pour ces prêts tressos et vous
pouvez encore en profiter jusqu'à
vendredi
il reste quelques places vendues 5 euros
alors un petit conseil venez à
l'hippodrome
une heure avant le début des épreuves et
ainsi vous pourrez peut-être imiter le
supplante aux australiens allez passons
à l'épreuve tant attendu demain
l'épreuve d'endurance dans la baie du
mont-saint-michel 160 km à parcourir en
cinq boucles jalonnée de contrôle
vétérinaire car le but c'est d'aller le
plus vite possible en ménageant sa
monture une discipline dans laquelle les
français ont brillé à de nombreuses
reprises ils ont notamment remporté
trois fois l'or par équipes on retrouve
dans l'effervescence de sortie bénédicte
et mon bon la sélectionneuse entraîneur
de l'équipe de france bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous alors la france est une
grande nation du rance
on n'a pas de médaille pour l'instant
est ce qu'on peut imaginer demain soir
sur le podium des français donc les
premières médailles pour la france
bonsoir oui j'espère qu'on peut imaginer
avoir un podium par équipes
en tout cas c'est notre but principal
l'équipe est une équipe motivée
et avec des cavaliers expérimentés et
des chevaux de haut niveau donc on a
toutes nos chances
maintenant c'est quand même un gros
championnat avec une participation
record
donc ça sera vraiment très difficile
alors vos principaux concurrents ce sont
les pays du golfe que souhaitez-vous un
temps pluvieux bien normand pour
déstabiliser ses cavaliers qui sont
habitués à courir dans le désert oui
mais en fait ce sont quand même des
cavaliers et des chevaux habitué à
courir sur tous les continents
donc je pense que quel que soit le temps
ils ont quand même du répondant c'est
pas ça qui va vraiment les handicapés
alors l'endurance et la deuxième
discipline etc est pratiquée en france
et pourtant elle n'est pas du tout connu
on ne connaît pas le nom de ces grands
cavaliers comment vous l'expliquez sait
qu'en cas veillez de ses grands chevaux
comment vous l'expliquez ben en fait
elle souffre de deux handicaps c'est à
dire que le premier c'est les moyens
qu'il faudrait mettre en oeuvre pour la
médiatisation qui serait très cher et
très compliqué puisque c'est quand même
sur une très longue distance et le
deuxième handicap c'est que c'est une
discipline qui n'est pas encore très
pratiqué dans les centres équestres et
donc la population qui monte à cheval
peu souvent l'occasion de pratiquer
cette discipline un mode et des chevaux
d'endurance qui sont des sacrés
champions 160 que le m on dit qu'en fait
ils peuvent parcourir plus de 160
kilomètres en une journée plus de 160 km
non au niveau ait fui les courses
maximales sont 160 km 1 il n'y a pas
plus de courses plus longues
lila il ya des courses qui font deux
fois 100 km c'est à dire 100 km en jour
100 km le lendemain ça c'est aussi un
format série 3 étoiles mais là que la
longueur maximale ses 160 km bon en tout
cas on est de tout coeur avec l'équipe
de france merci bénédicte et mon bon et
donc même chance bonne chance emmanuel
chaunu voilà un nouveau manège
oui merveille alors
bonne chance donc aux cavaliers français
47 nations sont engagés dans cette
épreuve qui se déroule il faut le dire
dans un climat assez particulier ces
dernières années plusieurs pays du golfe
ont été impliqués dans des affaires de
dopage et la suspicion plane il faut le
dire sur l'épreuve de demain pierre
marie piot cyril duponchel qu'est ce qui
fait courir les pur sang arabe
comment peuvent-ils la vallée 160 km à
22 km heure de moyenne dans la journée
comment un piètre cheval vendu au
moyen-orient peut-il subitement devenir
une bête de course
les soupçons de dopage les rumeurs de
corruption empoisonne le monde de
l'endurance et ses éleveurs bretons
rencontré près de sart qui dit sont
désemparés nous on aime on aime courir
les courses qu'on fait aujourd'hui
même monté à quelques niveaux supérieurs
on peut même plus parce qu'on n'a pas ce
petit quelque chose en plus qui fait que
l'on pourrait rivaliser avec avec
énormément de chevaux aujourd'hui pour
ce petit truc en plus c'est quoi ces
petits trucs en plus c'est que c'est ce
qu'on ne sait pas en fait il sait ce que
nous on ne sait pas pourtant nous nous
chauffons le travail comme avant mais
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus suivre c'est
vrai que ça fait peur ça fait peur
aujourd'hui par le biais de ce mondial
là
voilà il faut que choses s'arrêtent là
fédération internationale d'équitation a
bien tenté d'imposer de nouvelles règles
mais la suspicion vis toujours les
riches pays du golfe
dans ce contexte les cavaliers français
en sont réduits à espérer une médaille
par équipes enfin notre boulot notre
course comme on le fait tout au long de
l'année et un espérant que ça soit
équitable pour tout le monde et vous
n'êtes pas sûr pour l'instant non ce
n'est pas un peu décourageant parfois
s'y met on aime mettre au sport
90% des nations pratiquer notre sport de
manière propre avec le respect du cheval
et je pense pas qu'il faut pas se
laisser
manger par kaka variés qui essayent de
tricher
andré-jacques legoupil le dopage dans
l'endurance on en parle aussi beaucoup
parce que l'émir de dubaï qui a été
plusieurs fois éclaboussé par ces
affaires et les poules la princesse haya
qui la présidente de la fédération
équestre internationale
je pense qu'il est il est vrai que s'il
s'était appelé monsieur dupont on en
parlerait beaucoup moins mais ce que ce
que je viens d'entendre touche beaucoup
et que effectivement les les nations
étrangères se rebellent d'une part je
voudrais essayer de positiver en disant
qu à tout malheur quelque chose est bon
c'est à dire que effectivement si c'est
un maktoum qui s'est fait prendre
peut-être que ça va permettre et déjà la
fédération équestre internationale a
réagi ça va permettre
ils ont mis de nouvelles règles en place
donc là s'il ya encore de la triche ici
et y en a qui se font prendre c'est
vraiment qu'ils le veulent bien
et tant pis pour eux et moi j'espère que
d'un côté je vais nuancé ma réponse
j'espère que s'ils se font prendre il va
falloir que les sanctions et même pour
tous les sports soit beaucoup plus forte
que ça il n'y a pas de sanction à vie je
crois que pour tous les sports de haut
niveau il ya un moment exquis
ce qui caractérise le sport ce sont ces
règles sinon ils plus d'équité donc il
ya plus de sport le sport peut apporter
énormément de valeur
sauf que ya un moment pour sanctionner
pour vraiment sicile à la tape sur les
doigts pas assez forte billets risquent
de recommencer
donc on sanctionne et qu'on suspende à
vis de compétition en compétition de
très haut niveau
si la tricherie peut-être que ça fera
réfléchir d'une bonne foi mais c'est
aussi une remise en question qu'on doit
tout savoir et les supporters et les
médias et les financiers les
organisateurs parce que si on dit oh
quelle déception ils ne sont que
quatrièmes faut pas s'étonner de temps
en temps que l'être humain il pousse un
peu pour que le dopage n'est pas que
dans l'endurance il dans tous les sports
de haut niveau et dans tout l'espace et
castres y'a pas de raison qu'ils soient
que dans l'endurance et il doit l'être
dans le foot il doit l'être partout
il est dans la vie je voulais quand même
préciser une chose que notre le sport
équestre est peut-être l'un des plus
surveillés qu'ils soient je cherche pas
les excuses que le cheval c'est le taux
zéro c'est à dire que
vous vous êtes fatigué vous prenez un
café à cheval on peut pas lui donner de
café un cheval voulu donner une demie
barres de chocolat
dedans il ya de la caféine il sera
positif vous avez la vdn vous prenez un
cachet on ne peut pas donc ça nécessite
effectivement un entraînement
particulièrement suivi et tous les
vétérinaires sont là pour ça ce sont des
athlètes
si vous doutez qu'un cheval puisse
participer à 160km jouera pas d'un petit
peu d'histoire
les départements étaient calculées sur
la distance que pouvaient parcourir un
cheval dans une journée donc ait eu dans
le désert le cheval le pur sang arabe
est vraiment un cheval de marathon par
rapport à cheval de saut d'obstacles
dont il ya des règles donc qu'elle soit
respectée non à la triche
en revanche c'est possible c'est
possible je crois que lecavalier
française qui le disait tout à l'heure
vous le prouve alors cette épreuve
d'ambiance par rapport à tout ce qu'on
vient d'expliquer réclame une sacrée
organisation
il faut par exemple 5 soigneur par
chevaux les chevaux sont 170 les équipes
internationales ont donc recruté dans la
région et du coup l'un de nos boxeurs
les plus en vue du moment se retrouve
gros sur cette compétition il s'agit du
saint-lois maxime beaussire qui vise un
titre de champion de france stéphane
divine au jeu à la main depuis deux ans
il boxe dans la cour des grands à 23 ans
maxime beaussire a déjà fait 16 combats
en professionnel le saint-lois lisent
aujourd'hui le titre de champion de
france
d'habitude dans la lumière le voici
aujourd'hui qui fait partie des petites
mains des jeux équestres mondiaux vient
du milieu de la terre donc tu chasses en
donner je connais par coeur tout ça et
tu es tu vois là faut savoir rester les
pieds sur terre de toute façon quoi
qu'il arrive et puis toute façon je suis
pas encore j'ai encore toutes mes
preuves à faire dans le sport et puis et
puis même même fois qu'elles sont en
fait c'est ce genre de choses que je
continuerai à faire pour pour rester les
pieds sur terre surtout pendant ces deux
jours il assure l'assistance pour le
cheval dont il a la charge
un milieu qu'il connaît bien en fait et
depuis longtemps j'ai pratiqué cinq ans
rené club à saint lô quand j'étais gamin
puis après il s'est trouvé que ça a été
très bénéfique puisque
l'une est cavalière pro donc on a même à
cheval en commun et je continue à monter
à cheval a assez régulièrement
régulièrement entre deux entraînements
de boxe maxime beaussire devient gros
mhz pour une équipe de haut niveau
d'endurance cette fois ci il a été
embauché par hong kong
le cheval c'est comme le boxer aux
conneries sportif en est en général
c'est un véritable athlète et j'admire
ces animaux là après avoir tout préparé
pour la compétition de demain
maxime beaussire d'affilée ce soir vers
la salle de boxe la plus proche
demain il sera le soigneur du cheval
mais il n'oublie pas qu'en octobre il a
son propre combat emmanuel chaunu en
fait maxime beaussire peut boxer les
chevaux dopé ou plutôt les tricheurs
finalement l'ex de plus des tricheurs
autres épreuves qui commencent demain au
haras du pin dans l'orne le concours
complet le triathlon du cheval avec
d'abord le dressage ce sera demain et
vendredi les chevaux vous le voyons été
présentée aujourd'hui ce sont ceux qui
ont passé le contrôle vétérinaire et qui
sont prêt prêt à concourir
ils sont une petite centaine 1 28
nations participent à ce concours
complet qui s'annonce grandiose alors
les délégations sont arrivées il y a
quelques jours et pour les accueillir et
bien toute la zone autour du haras du
pin a été métamorphosée des temps des
containers des autels de fortune ont été
installés pour que les équipes puissent
rester le plus longtemps possible auprès
de leurs chevaux reportage d'abdel de
sachiez de damian mignon au coeur du
site classé du haras du pin des rangées
de containers 160 chambres deux étoiles
tous les cavaliers des fédérations sont
logés là avec les vétérinaires les chefs
d'equipe donc c'est l'hébergement
temporaire qui est la hype et qui repart
dans une semaine elle loue des chambres
tout confort avec climatisation
télévision et internet
douches toilettes et trois lignes à
c'est super c'est très proche avec les
chevalet c'est super c'est très pratique
en plus des cavaliers des vétérinaires
et des chefs d'equipe il a aussi fallu
trouver une solution pour loger tous
ceux qui s'occupent des chevaux au plus
près des écuries c'est une chambre pour
les grooms donc adoli ce sont des
contenaires pliable contrairement à ceux
pour les cavaliers
en plus de tous ces hôtels temporaire il
ya aussi ces camions qui ont servi à
amener les chevaux et dans lesquelles
vivent certains membres des délégations
il vient aussi très bien le coach est
séjour cuisine salle de bains est
parfaite tombe bien l'installer comme
dans un camping-car pour les jeux
équestres le haras du pin a dû se
métamorphoser en tout près de 300
personnes y songer et pendant les
compétitions des centaines de bénévoles
et jusqu'à 50000 spectateurs se rendront
sur le site
c'est un organisation monumentale que
quand on n'est pas dedans on peut pas
imaginer le boulot qui pourrait avoir
pour que tout marche comme il faut on a
prévu un planning en amont on a commencé
à installer le 1er août
donc on a réussi à monter ça dans un
temps record
donc tout tout cas tout est prêt pour
accueillir dès demain une des épreuves
les plus importantes de ces jeux le
concours complet emmanuel chaunu nous
rappelle que le haras du pin est situé
tout près du site d'enfouissement de
déchets ultimes de gde merci manuel
allez on passe au saut d'obstacles
l'épreuve reine c'est la semaine
prochaine à d'ornano
l'équipe de france dans laquelle on
compte trois bas normand a tenu un point
presse ce matin auprès d'auger près de
lisieux écouter l'entraîneur philippe
gardaz connais les aléas de notre sport
comme j'ai dit j'ai une équipe
formidable je suis fier de mes cavaliers
déjà au départ parce leur préparation
d'un dans le mental tout et tout est au
top en ce moment je veux vraiment dire
tout est dans le vert mais il ya
beaucoup d'équipés qui sont dans le même
cas donc sont quand même les aléas du
sport et parler de médaille avant
d'entrer sur la piste c'est quand même
un rôle auquel je ne veux pas m'astreins
parce que même de grandes équipes plus
grande que nous avons passés au travers
c'est toujours comme ça dans les
championnats donc c'est pour ça que je
reste quand même
petit peu sur la réserve elle est
revenue au village des jeux où il se
passe toujours quelque chose ces images
de cavalière qui monte aujourd'hui en
amazone sur un jeu du spectacle andré
jacq
si je lis et élégant et ça peut paraître
bizarre vous avez présenté une seule
amazone houara du pain cet été vous les
deux fourches qui a sous la jupe en fait
on peut pas tomber tu tousses et ont
fait une clé avec ses jambes et ça
permettait aux femmes à l'époque de
pouvoir monter à cheval puisqu'il était
mal venu de voir ces dames assise à
califourchon
voilà et ça a passé les siècles et
l'équitation est un sport que hommes et
femmes pratiquent ensemble
rappelons le le réglage des jeux où sont
présents nos confrères de france bleu
aurélie misery bonsoir que propose-t-il
pendant ce temps des gemmes montant à
france bleu radio officielle des jeux
équestres mondiaux qui va proposer à ses
400 mille auditeurs de basse et de haute
normandie plus de 60 heures de direct et
pour en savoir plus avec nous le
directeur de france bleu basse-normandie
pierre de st bonsoir
alors vous prenez l'antenne dès 14
heures tous les jours vous ne lâchez
plus le micro jusqu'à 19 heures qu'est
ce que vous allez proposer pendant cette
tranche horaire très large
alors nous allons proposer des émissions
spéciales des interviews des chroniques
beaucoup d'infos pratiques et d'info
trafic pour permettre en fait aux
auditeurs de france bleu vient de
réussir ces jeux équestres mondiaux et
de profiter de la fête et puis des infos
people oui tout à fait puisque tous les
soirs il ya le magazine des jeux à 18
heures donc c'est du sport avec les
stars de l'équitation tous les champions
bien sûr mais les vedettes qui viennent
sur le village d eux et qu'ils sont des
people alors on rappelle les horaires
14h 19h en semaine 16 heures 19 heures
le week-end trois temps forts également
à noter oui à ne pas manquer dès samedi
le professeur gersal et sa nouvelle
émission à partir de 13h30 consacré aux
j'aime bien sûr nathalie simon qui aura
comme invités véronique jannot l'une des
ambassadrices des jeux équestres
mondiaux dès samedi soir à 19h30 et
enfin mercredi en direct daniela
lumbroso pour son émission france bleu
midi ensemble avec d'un jamin castaldi
et tous ses invités à partir de midi
beau programme merci beaucoup
pierre 200 et puis n'oubliez pas de
regarder france 3 puisque nous sommes à
tous les jours aurélie aller comme tous
les soirs notre chronique les pieds dans
le groupe 1
mathieu bellingen nous propose un autre
regard sur ces jeux ce soir il est à
saint lô pour essayer de comprendre ce
qu'est le horse ball qui est en
démonstration à partir de ce soir
alors voilà c'est un entraînement de
l'équipe de france de horse ball le
horse ball ne fait pas partie des jeux
équestres et pourquoi il n'y a pas de
cheval mathilde ya pas de cheval je
comprends pas que si vous faites là non
les cheveux sont pas encore mais la
travailler la tactique on s'entraîne
pour ce soir d'accord pour pouvoir être
prête pour le match et social les quatre
joueuses doivent faire trois passes avec
leur ballon équipé de sangles avant de
marquer le horse ball est une discipline
et en france elle est en démonstration à
saint-lô jusqu'à vendredi et un petit
jouet à tout âge il suffit d'avoir une
monture à sa hauteur finalement
d
or voilà je crois que j'ai raté ma
vocation de bien deux buts oranje bol
d'or est un peu je pense aller les jeux
équestres mondiaux c'est aussi
l'occasion de découvrir des sports et
cassent plus confidentiels comme le polo
cross une discipline venue d'australie
et ses anciennes pratiques et dans les
pays du commonwealth et qui se joue avec
une épuisette à ne pas confondre avec le
polo et ça se joue enfants salle et
emmanuel chaunu ça suffit cette
suspicion sur les pays du golfe à voilà
c'est je sais j'en pratique juste la
médecine traditionnelle l'acupuncture
temps on a plutôt la voilà donc voilà ma
à demain messieurs vrai bal ce soir et
demain
il
oui